[Music]
welcome to world stories
[Music]
India education for girls Germany
Assyrian becomes a fireman but we begin
in Northern Ireland after pregnant this
will be the only part of Britain to
share a land border with the European
Union a local artist has found a novel
way to draw attention to this by jogging
she takes the freedom of movement in the
EU literally Alex stannic a fine art
ratchet from Northern Ireland has run
the length of the Irish border 360
kilometers in 7 days for me as an artist
and as a runner and as a young person
there's something to be said for the
fact that I can just I could do this and
over the course of a week I can go on
this crazy run you know it's some kind
of crazy travel but I'm free to enter
and exit different countries
Alex tannic is originally from Poland
and has been living in Northern Ireland
since she was 11 her aim is to highlight
the invisible border separating Northern
Ireland in the UK and the Republic of
Ireland her partner hopes that a return
of border checkpoints can be avoided
it's a something I think that's not
really felt in London and the tree
implication the way in which the border
runs means there's divisions halfway
through a road or through a field it's
not a traditional border in terms of
rivers and things like that it makes it
extremely difficult if a hard border was
to come into place with her performance
Alex tannic also hopes to raise
awareness about the uncertainty felt by
EU Nationals as a result of Britain's
votes to leafy you I think if the
referendum didn't happen
I think some people would have just the
same attitudes they'd still see us as
second-class citizens now there's just
an allowance for that to be out in the
open and for me and my family that was I
think the biggest blow it definitely
took a blow for us feeling secure and
feeling like we're welcome Northern
Ireland voted against brexit with 56% of
the population in opposition Alex now
hopes that more people will follow her
footsteps and make their voices heard
India is home to an estimated 400
million people who can't read or write
the rate of illiteracy is especially
high among women many of whom can barely
write their names thirteen year old
Satya Khan wants to do much more than
that
Satya Khan has already been in class the
entire day but she's still eager for
more hardly anything can stop this
thirteen-year-old from pursuing her love
of learning everyone's hope I'd love to
come to school even if I'm tired if I
get a fever if I'm also sick so that
time also come to school the first time
she went to school was seven years ago
in a village just outside India's
capital New Delhi she got there thanks
to literacy India an organization that
helps underprivileged children who would
otherwise not be in school the
organization focuses particularly on
young girls their education czar often
neglected in rural communities out of
safety concerns or because parents need
them to help run the household and
although India passed the Right to
Education Act in 2009 challenges still
remain definitely right to education
Hill and he has brought some changes in
the terms of more enrollment more
attendance more facilities into the
school but in terms of the changing the
minds of the communities it's not
effective so to change the mindset of
the committee we'll have to go on the
ground it will have to reach them you'll
have to convince them so I think it will
take time
Sadia represents of what can happen when
these kinds of challenges are overcome
she lives walking distance from the
school and shares a room with her
parents and sister the family doesn't
have a lot of money and neither parent
received much of an education for her
mother Raveena school was never an
option growing up but today she feels
her lack of education limits what she
can do and wants a different life for
her daughter's this I feel very sad that
I'm not educated I've only had just a
little bit of schooling
but now when I want to use the phone I
need to wait for my children or my
husband to help and there are lots of
things like that that I have to think
about
Sonya's father azim dyes clothes for a
living but business is slow right now
the machines he usually works with are
barely in use Azim doesn't have the
qualifications to change professions
easily so he sees sadhyas education as a
potential opportunity for the entire
family that if she studies and make
something of herself then it will be to
our benefit our life will change and so
will hers they will definitely be
changed and it will be good the signs
are promising Satya already uses what
she's learned to help her father with
things he used to struggle with like
taking orders or writing bills and
sadhyas recent admission to a more
established school is also a major step
one she hopes will help her achieve her
dream
it's been two years since Monier
al-sheikh fled Syria like hundreds of
thousands of other refugees he struggled
through the Balkans before finally
reaching his goal Germany DW has been
taking a look at how he's faring Monier
al-sheikh is the newest member of the
volunteer fire brigade in the western
town of Augsburg once a week the fire
fighters gather to simulate a rescue
operation it's challenging but familiar
taking part in these exercises is
important
this is devastation as a refugee it's
very important to give something back
these people have opened their doors to
us and we have to show them that we're
grateful it's our duty one of the
biggest hurdles for Munir is
understanding the orders
slowly but surely he's beginning to find
his feet in the beginning it's difficult
to wrap your head around everything but
he's doing really well
and it's lonely getting to grips with
the specialist vocabulary we use here
when he's not at the fire station monia
volunteers in the local community
helping with odd jobs like hedge
trimming after arriving in Germany he
founded the initiative new neighbors to
help migrants integrate he became a
point of contact for new arrivals
helping other migrants with bureaucracy
and coming to terms with life in Germany
despite his volunteer work monir is
struggling himself he was only recently
able to find his own apartment and
despite his best efforts is still
searching for a paid job for now he has
to make do with the 300 euros he
receives from the government each month
many are often thinks back to two years
ago then he was travelling to Germany
along the so called balcan route but got
stranded in angery the situation in
Hungary was unbelievable we slept on the
ground for four days said that if the
situation doesn't improve I'll just have
to go back to Syria
[Music]
eventually the border opened and one
year was taken to Germany by bus along
with thousands of others now he's trying
to make a new home here he's applied for
nearly 50 jobs across the country
every time this application has been
rejected life in Germany he says is
harder than he ever would have imagined
[Music]
we share was until recently one of the
people smuggling hubs of Africa Bashir
AMA was involved in this illegal
business in the desert city of Agadez
but since the government started
cracking down on illegal migration
people smugglers have had to find other
work Bashir amah
has a lot of time on his hands to talk
shop with the club soccer trainer Bashir
used to make a lot of money by helping
migrants across the Sahara Desert all
the way to Libya but when the government
cracked down on people smugglers Bashir
decided to call it quits he now helps
fund the city's biggest soccer club this
is the club of people smugglers I'm a
people smuggler the Vice President is a
people smuggler and so is everyone who's
in charge here and so with the investors
his experience as a smuggler comes in
handy for Bashir's latest business deal
eight of his players are migrants who
had been stranded in Agadez where Bashir
recruited them for his team player 66
from Ivory Coast also once dreamed of
becoming a soccer superstar in Europe
instead Muhammadu now plays for
Basheer's club efforts this season
wasn't going so well but next season
it's going to be better but sure now
tries to prevent them from making the
trek to Europe mostly because it's in
his own interest they are his top
players after all but also because more
and more ruthless gangs are taking over
new shares trafficking business the
roots are checked everywhere at the
moment that's why the traffickers take
different routes through the desert and
they're very dangerous
Bashir takes us to one of the hidden
desert cities just outside of Anka des
where many of the new gangs are
operating from it's said to be ruled by
the Mafia this visit is not without risk
for the former people smuggler relations
with the new guys are understandably
strained but he says he's well-connected
so they won't harm him he's mostly
interested in scouting Talent
among the hundreds of stranded migrants
who ran out of money to continue their
travels many have been stuck here for
months but nothing seems to deter them
from their journey my final destination
is Europe no matter what obstacles I run
into I'm not afraid I'm only gonna die
once in the end Bashir manages to find a
potential soccer player from Ivory Coast
and invites him to come to tryouts
it's where he will have to prove he has
enough talent to play for New Year 2nd
division and most importantly whether he
is ready to give up his dream of Europe
for now
[Music]
you